we live in a free country again what's a  free country there's a powerful idea  that's a that's a magnificent way to  live  oh I see one  hello hey how's it going you want come  over and party or something party Kay  it's me guess who mother good morning I  am NOT the same this is just a  forewarning eat so hard make them girls  come swarming and they like to touch my  hair and tell me that I'm charters of  the American Dream and my peace be so  alarmed  I don't anything in this life history's  taught us anything this is America land  of the brave  if one with a second chances  there is a place  is that an American flag you have on  this sir I have fashioned this American  flag into a diaper  terrorize this